le reçu pour celle de tout compte c'est
quoi c'est un document qui va lister
l'ensemble des sommes qui te sont dus et
que ton employeur te règle au monde au
moment de ton départ je suis Awa Fofana
dirigeante de check tape une start-up
qui aide les salariés à mieux comprendre
leur bulletin de salaire elle a été
créée en octobre 2022 et elle est
implantée à Élancourt
[Musique]
alors check tapis c'est une communauté
de salariés qui essaye de mieux
comprendre leur bulletin de salaire on
est présent sur les réseaux sociaux
Instagram LinkedIn Tik Tok et bien
d'autres on est un peu plus de 20000
aujourd'hui et l'objectif c'est vraiment
d'essayer de détecter les erreurs de nos
bulletins de salaire pour ne pas se
faire avoir
[Musique]
on va pouvoir être mis en relation avec
un expert paye indépendant qui va
pouvoir regarder bulletin de salaire et
déterminer si oui ou non il y a une
erreur et nous donner les arguments pour
aller faire une réclamation éventuelle
auprès de notre employeur si il constate
une anomalie de l'autre côté on va aussi
pouvoir avoir des formations pour les
salariés pour leur apprendre à mieux
lire leurs bulletin de salaire puisqu'il
y a à l'école on nous apprend pas
comment marche une fiche de paie
[Musique]
alors moi ça fait plus de 12 ans que je
travaille en paie j'ai une expérience de
gestionnaire de paie ensuite j'ai évolué
vers des postes de consultante et de
chef de projet à SIRH et pendant toutes
ces expériences je suis passé par
beaucoup d'entreprises et je me suis
rendu compte que de l'ouvrier jusqu'au
cadre supérieur personne ne comprend
rien à son bulletin de salaire et
parfois ça a des conséquences négatives
pour les salariés puisqu'ils peuvent
perdre de l'argent
[Musique]
on vient juste de démarrer avec
l'entreprise a été créée en octobre 2022
on a commencé les prestations et pour
l'instant je suis la seule gestionnaire
de paie à le proposer mais aujourd'hui
on essaye d'agrandir l'équipe de checker
de paye pour pouvoir être plus nombreux
à répondre en fait aux besoins des
salariés
[Musique]
j'ai besoin de créer un business model
qui fonctionne et qui est rentable j'ai
besoin aussi d'accompagnement pour
savoir comment recrute je suis junior
pour tous ces aspects là et donc c'est
pour ça que j'ai besoin de
l'accompagnement de ski cube pour
m'aider à faire cela aujourd'hui en
France si tu es salarié ton employeur se
substitue à ton comptable puisqu'il est
chargé de recouvrer tes cotisations et
de les reverser aux administrations
comme la retraite la sécurité sociale ou
encore le Pôle emploi et si ta confiance
a été mal placée si tu ne contrôle pas
tes bulletins de salaire il est possible
que tu te retrouves dans une situation
financière très délicate que ce soit
maintenant ou bien plus tard